This is part two
of the FOM lecture
on head and
neck embryology.
This is going to
be on structures
that deviate from the
segmented pharyngeal
structures.
We'll start off
with the tongue.
So tongue
development traverses
multiple pharyngeal
arches, hence
why they have
complex innervations.
So when you look at
the figure up the
top row, you see
that pharyngeal
arch 1 extends as it
grows and forms the
anterior two-thirds
of the tongue.
When you look at
arch 2, you see that
arch 3 begins to
overgrow over arch
2. So arch 2 essentially
disappears, at
least from the
external surface of
the tongue, but
still provides taste
innervation to the
anterior two-thirds.
And arch 3 and 4
form the mucosa of
the posterior one
-third of the tongue.
and tongue muscles
that form and are
underlying these
external surfaces in the
mucosa are formed from
the occipital somites
which I mentioned
towards the beginning
of this lecture and
that's why cranial
nerve 12 provides
the motor innervation
which is the caudal
most cranial nerve
and this makes
sense when you think
about the complex
sensory innervation
to the tongue so So
anterior two-thirds,
the somatic sensory
innervation is
provided by cranial
nerve 5, which
is associated with
pharyngeal arch 1.
And then the
taste for anterior
two-thirds of the
tongue is provided
by cranial nerve
7, or facial.
And then pharyngeal
arch 3 provides the
mucosal and the taste
innervation for the
posterior one-third of
the tongue. And that's
why both the somatic
sensory and the special
taste sensory innervation
is provided by the
glossopharyngeal nerve
for the posterior
one-third of the tongue.
And then even more
posterior to that,
both the taste and the
somatic sensory
innervation is provided by
the vagus nerve, which
comes from arch four.
Next up is thyroid.
thyroid and thyroid
originates from the
single outpouching of
endoderm shown here on
the ventral side between
arches one and two
and this is called
the thyroid diverticulum
and diverticulum
just means an outpocketing
and this exists
if you go back one slide
at the foramen cecum
which is between the
area of the tongue
that's formed by arch
one and arch three.
Now let's talk about
thyroid development.
So the thyroid originates
from the single
outpocketing on the
endoderm on the ventral
side between arches
one and two. So if you
go back one slide, you
can see this foramen
cecum that exists
between the area of the
tongue formed by arch
one and arch three.
and so remember that
diverticulum means
outpocketing so this is
just a small outpocketing
that will eventually
become the thyroid
gland and during
development as the
embryo and the tongue
grow the developing
thyroid gland descends
down the neck so it
starts out as a thyroid
primordium or the
diverticulum but it
starts to descend through
the neck passing
through the developing
higher bone and laryngeal
cartilages. And as
it goes down, it
generates or produces this
narrow duct called
a thyroglossal duct.
And as it continues
or the thyroid
gland continues
downward, it's
going to create a
longer thyroglossal
duct along the
midline anterior
side of the neck and
after a while the
thyroglossal duct
degenerates and then
what only what
remains is the opening
pit of the thyroglossal
duct called the
foramen cecum which
we saw on one of the
previous slides and
this figure shows
the pathway that the
thyroglossal duct
took towards the
thyroid gland.
So clinical correlate
related to the
thyroglossal duct is what
happens when this duct
does not close up
or does not get
obliterated. That will
lead to the thyroglossal
duct sinus or thyroglossal
duct cyst. And
the difference between
the two is that
thyroduct cyst, let's
start with there in the
middle of the slide,
is there will be a
cavity or cyst that
remains because the
thyroglossal duct did
not seal up properly.
On the other hand,
thyroglossal duct cyst
forms, or excuse me,
thyroglossal duct
sinus forms when
there's an opening to
an external environment.
And both the cyst
and sinus pose a risk
because infection
can start and spread
within the cyst.
So keep in mind that
thyroglossal duct
cyst forms along
the midline of the
neck, not lateral like
the branchial cysts.
So make sure that
you pay attention
to the location of
this opening to decide
whether it is due
to the thyroglossal
duct cyst or sinus
or branchial cyst.
The third clinical
correlate related to the
thyroid gland and the
thyroglossal duct is
an ectopic thyroid
gland. And this is fairly
common. And the most
common presence or
presentation of this is
the pyramidal lobe, which
is a little extension
along the midline of
the thyroid gland so
the thyroid gland is
usually h-shaped but
sometimes you'll see
this extension along the
midline pointing upwards
and this is called
the pyramidal lobe and
this is just the thyroid
gland growing along
just the short end portion
of the phyroglossal
duct and this is not
this does not pose
any risk to someone's
health and you might
see it on your cadaver
in the anatomy lab.
Another special
developmental process that
occurs in the head
is called placodes.
And so placodes are
ectodermal discs that
form from this thin
ectodermal layer. So when
the ectodermal layer
during development
invaginates, so again
forming and in-pocketing
and buds off, as you
can see on this lower
left-hand corner,
then it forms what's
called a placode. And
there are a number of
special sensory structures
that are derived
from placodes. So
these include the nasal
placode, which will
form the mucosa of the
nasal cavity. So that's
going to be closely
associated with the sense
of smell or olfaction.
The lens placode,
which forms the lens
of the eye, the otic
placode, which forms
the vestibule and
cochlea of the inner ear,
and it also forms
neurogenic placoids,
which forms parts of
the cranial nerves.
So as I mentioned,
these placodes tend
to be associated
closely with cranial
nerves and especially
special sensory nerves.
So nasal placode
is associated with
cranial nerve one or
the olfactory nerve.
Lens placode is
closely associated with
the optic nerve.
and the otic placode
is closely
associated with the
vestibulocochlear nerve
or cranial nerve eight.
Now let's talk about the
development of the face.
So the facial primordia
or the precursor to
the face begins with
three major regions. So
you have the frontal
nasal prominence here
and you have the
maxillary prominences just
above the stomodium
or the embryonic mouth
and then the mandibular
prominences and these
three major regions will
differentiate further
so at six weeks old
the frontal nasal
prominence will divide
into sort of the frontal
area and then the
nasal process over here
on each side of the
embryonic face so on the
lateral side this lateral
nasal process will
eventually form the
sides of the nose which
you can kind of follow
along in the seven
and eight weak embryos.
And then the medial
nasal process will come
together to form the
intermaxillary segment
shown here in yellow.
And this will form
the nasal septum, the
middle part of the upper
lip and the philtrum
or the medial cleft,
which you can see
here on the lower right
part of the image.
and then the
left and right
maxillary prominences
will come meet
the intermaxillary
prominences
to form the upper
cheek regions and
the upper lip shown
here in blue and
then the left and
right mandibular
prominences will
form the lower jaw
lower lip and the
lower cheek regions
so now let's take
the video that we saw
at the very beginning
of this lecture
and just go over
what we just learned.
So here we have the
frontal nasal prominence,
and you have the
nasal process forming
here. You have the
maxillary process here,
and then you have the
mandibular process
over here. And here
are the lateral and
the medial portion of
the nasal processes,
which is going
to meet to form
the intermaxillary
process.
And then those will
further develop and
differentiate to form
the face of a fetus.
So there's a
clinical correlate
associated with the
formation of the
face as well as
the hard palate.
So the palate forms
through two stages.
So we have the primary
palate, which is
formed from the extension
of the intermaxillary
segment. So this was
the yellow portion
that we also saw
in two slides ago
before we played the
video. And this will
form what's called,
again, the primary palate,
if you follow it
to the right of the
image. The secondary
pallet forms from
joining of the pallet
time process coming from
the maxillary
prominences in blue here.
So in this view,
we're looking
at the embryo
bottom up. So
we're looking up
at the pallet.
And by the end, both
of these pallets will
close up, forming a
unified hard pallet.
So the clinical
correlate portion comes
when there is incomplete
fusion enclosure of
the maxilla and your
palate. And this is
actually pretty common.
So occurs in about
one in 1000 births.
And the cleft lip
originates from incomplete
fusion around the
lip between the
intermaxillary segment and
the palatine process.
and the more severe
version is the cleft
palate where you have
opening within the
hard palate due to the
incomplete fusion of
the path time process
on both sides as well
as the primary palate
formed from the
intermaxillary segment.
So this results in
abnormal facial appearance
and defective speech
and nowadays it can
be treated in most cases
and involves surgery
and any therapies,
for example, speech
therapies to improve
associated conditions.
So when you have a
cleft palate, it means
that the oral and nasal
cavities are connected.
So that definitely
needs to be treated in
order to prevent issues
with, for example,
feeding.
Now let's talk about
skull development.
So I'm going to
go through this
briefly, and you do
not need to know the
details as on this
slide for the exam.
So you have three
embryonic components
that make up the
skull. So you have the
chondrocranium,
which is formed from
endochondral bones, so
bones that start off as
cartilage and then
transforms into bone.
So these include the
occipital, sphenoid,
ethmoid, and
temporal bones, at
least the petrous
or the hard part
where the middle and
inner ear resides.
You also have the
desmocranium, which is
the membranous bone
to the sides and tops
of the brain case,
forms the calvary.
And these include
the frontal,
occipital, and
the parietal.
Although this is shown
in blue, parts of
it should be membranous
bone in purple.
You also have
viscerocranium, which is
derived from pharyngeal
arches via, again,
membranous ossification.
So these include
the temporal bone, the
squamous part, or the
flat part, maxillabone,
zygomatic, and
the mandible bone,
shown here in the image.
Brain development,
similarly, you
don't need to know
anything on this
slide, but just wanted
to let you know
that the neural
tube, which you
should have gone over
in one of the first
embryo lectures,
becomes more differentiated
into the forebrain,
midbrain, and hindbrain,
and these will
further differentiate
into different
subdivisions of the
brain. You will cover
neuronality in more
detail next semester. But
the reason why I went
over the skull and brain
development, even
if it briefly, is to
talk about some important
clinical correlates
that is caused by
deviations from this
coordinated development
of the brain and skull
they have to develop
together but what if
it doesn't so one of
the conditions that
could occur is called
craniosynostosis and
this is deformity of
the skull due to the
********* closure of
the sutures which means
that the fontanelle is
closed too early and
so the type of defect
and the deformation
depends on which suture
closed prematurely.
Microcephaly is having
a smaller brain. It's
caused by abnormal
development of the brain
rather than anything
to do with suture
closure and timing thereof
of the skull. And it
often results in mental
deficiency because
it's the brain tissue
that's being affected.
And then finally, we
have hydrocephalus,
which is caused by
elevated pressure in
the brain ventricles
due to excess cerebral
spinal fluid buildup.
So this results
in larger brains, which
then pushes against
the skull during
skull development. So
this leads to this
expanded brain case
morphology. And this
is pretty common, which
occurs in one in
about thousand births.
And finally, in
this part, I'm going
to be talking
about pituitary and
their amazing
developmental origins.
So the pituitary,
also known as
hypothesis, is a
master endocrine gland.
And this is especially
true for growth and
reproduction. And the
anterior and posterior
lobes produce different
sets of hormones,
which you can see here,
but this is not going
to be tested, at
least for this lecture
content. So don't worry
about this for now.
But what's interesting
and what you will
get tested on is the
developmental or embryonic
origins of anterior
versus the posterior
lobe or the pituitary.
And I think it's
very neat. So what
happens is that the
anterior lobe forms
from the upgrowth of the
roof of the mouth,
which you can see here.
And this is called
the hypophysiopouch.
And then the posterior
lobe comes from
above, from the
downgrowth of the floor of
the embryonic brain,
the diencephalon.
And the brain is
originally from ectoderm.
So they're both
ectodermal in their
origins, but obviously
they're coming from
totally different
parts or tissues, which
is remarkable. And the
anterior and posterior
lobes of the the
pituitary, while
these pouches kind
of dance together and
come together to eventually
form the anterior
and posterior lobes
of the pituitary.